count us up there um so when I rorty's
saying hi I knew Rorion so we were
friends he what he wanted to do was and
force a doing a pretty thick John Dewey
and view of democracy on people and I
just felt impressive to me but you you
raise the really important question of
course Kent can we eliminate all
everything of that sort won't there be a
more gap but you know why goes back to
the fear of all these people I mean what
do you mean a state which is not unified
by some which does not have some sort of
religious moral unity and the people now
so a liberal democracy is clearly not an
it's clearly not a neutral arrangement I
mean it's obviously got commitments I
think it's got deep commitment to human
rights and the people somebody does
things that there are no human rights
and they've got real trouble with the
liberal democracy so so I said is the
accusation is that it's are more I don't
believe that in fact it is the moral
structure of its own sword very
different very different from previous
ones but it's not in our moral structure
but I think on lots of issues that we
debate we live with the reality that we
don't have a shared I mean so the shared
structural principles but we live with
the reality that we don't have shared
principles which are going to yield
consensus the present healthcare debate
is messy because it's filled with so
many economic complications and so forth
I think the cleanest illustration of
this point was the debate over physician
assisted suicide which took place in the
state of Oregon about 15 years ago
economics with not well I mean a few
people raised in economic issue is just
too expensive to take care of all people
by and large that and and what you what
you found was a whole and what you found
was a whole array of fast and
fascinatingly articulate but different
more positions coming out not one but
not one second one not one
religious one there was no religious
person who was so heavy-handed as to say
God told me last night that
physician-assisted suicide was wrong so
it is that's the end of the matter
nobody's the sole flat-footed does that
you had utilitarians and you had these
economizers who's that it's just too
expensive to take care of old people and
so forth um what we have what we do at
the end of the day is take a vote we
haven't achieved consensus we take a
vote and that's a mighty risky procedure
um you know of a better one right at my
question what's your option so I'm just
going to force uniform not only concern
is that how do we ensure that people
respect there being a vote for instance
is that something that we just assumed
that people will always out let's go to
a book that seems to me something that
does require particular cultivation of
such and I'm concerned that he's saying
we shouldn't traffic in the business of
comprehensive doctrines runs the risk of
let's get into a point where the boat is
not going in fact go back so I think we
have to pay a lot of attention to the
character of the preliminary debate
things that Tony said things that I said
a lot of attention to that then and one
of the things one of the things one of
the reasons that each of us should
listen to the voice of the other is so
that when we decide to vote against them
finally against their position we know
what we're voting against we are voting
against Joel who has expressed with
great eloquence his own whatever moves
in Jewish Buddhist position whatever and
now I find I still disagree with them
and I have to vote against him I think
it's um I think that's one of the
reasons why it's important to allow
these voices to come force it so we know
so I'm if I'm voting against Joel I know
who it is you know what position it is
that I'm actually voting against but
then we have to take take the vote and
try to make that vote as fair as
possible so here's so here's what's
here's what eating here's what's guiding
people like Audi and Rawls and so forth
a noble vision of a society in which all
of us are co-authors of the legislation
we are co-authors nobody's handing it
down we are co-authors that's that's the
basic idea and if you're a co-author
you're not coerced right perforce I
think that's a noble idea it just
doesn't work asuma procedures and within
those democratic procedures there are
values in virtual semesters their
substantive virtues embedded in the very
democratic right we got it we were sure
about the virtues which you're pushing
of the process and the debate absolutely
right my lamentos that were violating
those virtues flamboyantly in the u.s.
today very I mean I think it's so I was
thinking we're about debates on over the
vote and so on and various pieces that
were put forward there was a when you
lead a political party basically you you
you were the recipient of a lot of
advice and are varying degrees of sense
and the first leader of the British
Labour Party was a Scots guy called Keir
Hardie who's very tough-minded Garvey
who's trying to get the party off the
ground of win support and in an election
this was before women's suffrage and the
Pankhurst sisters who were campaigning
for women's suffrage they'd also a part
of their work was they studied the
instance of various sexual diseases and
they come to inclusion this was all
because of the proclivities of men and
they wrote that the sisters wrote to
Keir Hardie was the leader and said
before the election they said we would
like to put forward the following
proposition to you that you campaign on
a a slogan of votes for women and
abstinence for men to which care how do
you reply is that thank you very much
for advice the election would
propensity zuv which are not immediately
discernible so don't know why I
mentioned that but anyway and I think
you see I think that that the I think
Nick met a very important point about
the Plymouth the preliminary debate at
least has got to be drawn in a very
careful way you see um I mean I place
the me Nathan was asking me for
practical examples I mean just to give a
couple we had a I started a program of
schools in in the UK slightly similar to
your charter schools but they were
recorded as the Academy system which is
now you know developed in a major part
of our secondary school system but there
was a there was a major plan through
posed to want to start such schools up
and up in the Northeast and who's a
creationist and the question arose
whether as a creationist it was right
that he could start these schools
because of the influence on the children
Lee and you know sometimes at the cusp
of these things you have to decide it in
quite a difficult way so we decided in
the end I decided he should be able to
start their schools but he could not
teach creationism as the you know he
could not contradict the the curriculum
now you need I think you know to have
certain to get this attitude of mind I
don't think you can leave it to chance
and this is where I do like Kenneth was
saying and so I believe for example that
because of the importance datas reason
for this course and that the reason I
think why education policies got to take
account of the fact that the religious
and faith literacy today is an important
part of understanding the society and
world in which you grow up and therefore
i think that needs to amend you know the
policy that the that we have now does
that mean that everybody will agree no
and does that mean occasionally as with
switzerland that you end up in a
situation where people collectively take
an action that is
contrary to the basic to really what the
country is about actually no it doesn't
mean that you will get that but that
makes it all the more important for that
open attitude to be I think quite quite
a deliberative proposition advanced
number on behalf of the it does of a
constitution but the Constitution tends
to focus more on the sort of technical
you know the division between the powers
of the central government for the
Canton's and so on and doesn't it
doesn't human rights legislation now I
think what one thing that is interesting
is this and both Allen's point and
Reuters points to this I think that
there will inevitably be situations in
which is a complete right i mean and
what's more and i think this is a very
important point about the way things
evolve I mean I used to study the
American constitutional cases you know
brown on the board of education and so
on and so forth and the fact is what
happened was that the courts in a sense
reflected as their decisions change the
evolution of society and so certain
attitudes held at one time became
overtime unacceptable attitudes now but
here's what I think is important though
the fact that you had a proper due
process and the fact that you had a
framework within which these arguments
take place I think is is of itself
helpful and that it takes place by
reference to an argument that is an
argument that in some sense is I think
morally and not merely contractually
inspired now I think you know so when I
was coming your age a student i used to
say look really all has happened is
society's changed but now i take a
slightly more sophisticated view of that
process and think yes it's true but
actually the very fact that there was a
processed within which these the
his issues were aired and determined
that had reference to this
constitutional framework of Rights was
actually very important in resolving
this in in the correct way and you might
have waited instantly a lot longer for
some of these decisions to come right
were it not for that fact now it is
however a situation in which it does
call for open attitudes from the
non-religious and the religious and
where you you get on where you get for
example a closed attitude on behalf of
the religious you will get the reaction
from the non-religious and that's why
this debate it's quite important that
it's it seized by what I would say is a
sort of sensible and intelligent
consensual middle ground to to push the
extremes back because em let's be very
clear about this the reaction in parts
of Europe that is taken on in certain
occasions an anti-islamic character is
as a result of the feeling that there
are those within the religious faith of
Islam who are pushing what people think
is an inconsistent view of our basic
politics on the rest of the population
so that's why you need this is why i say
i think this this debate because i
really do believe in a sense that for
the majority people I mean what Nick
knickers outline is you know I think as
a I mean I think would kind of win the
election as it were I mean you know in
other words most people would say well
that seems to be sensible enough because
it's it's a pretty open attitude but it
has to be something that is then is the
policy conclusion from that that
interests me there's how you then
inculcate and encourage that how civic
society not just government takes a role
in that how academic institutions also
develop the the research that that shows
that the open societies can also lead to
to greater in in endeavor and prosperity
and you know I was saying to the
colleagues who
here from Peking University today that
one really interesting thing to me is in
China how the modern leadership is
referencing it's it's open policy today
not to the changes of the 60 years since
the the revolution in China but actually
way back in time to say when
Confucianism was was was developing and
China was at that point a very open
trading nation that was when it was
successful he then closed down became
unsuccessful now it's opening up again
it you know and I think these things
have to be fought for that's my point so
when you look at the Netherlands I mean
most most people are obviously shocked
at what happened but the only way of
retrieving this situation is to try and
give some sense of a common space in it
and a common set of shared purposes and
values so for example after the London
bombing and in july two thousand and
five in my first statement I mean I knew
you would get at a later stage to other
things but my first statement was a
statement about shared values about the
fact that any anti-muslim sentiment
coming out of this would be wrong and
regressive and undermined the basis of
our society right so that was my first
almost kind of like a philosophical
political statement to bring people
together but I was also aware and I got
to this a few months later and people
kind of thought one was inconsistent
with the other where I said right now
we're also going to introduce the
following rules right we are not going
to have a man's coming in from abroad
who are not certified by some process as
having a certain amount of religious
achievement and also applica attitude
what we can't afford to have someone who
coming into our society saying you are
the enemy if you're not of my religion
so then people said words you know this
is this very nice broad philosophical
statement and now you're taking some
quite tough measures here but I said no
the one
is necessary in order to protect the
other and actually what happens is and I
have this debate often with people on
the the progressive side of politics is
that such open attitudes and the
protection of your basic common space it
doesn't happen by accident right and it
there are plenty of people who it might
happen naturally but there are also
people prepared to interfere with that
process and so you do have to you know
the policy implications of this I think
are quite quite profound and make a lot
of difference in the way that politics
then interact with the world of religion
the score this point did a Swiss case of
the band if I'm informed correctly it is
the complacency of the opponents of the
band that allowed the band to go through
they simply took it for granted that
Swiss will not pass the vote right so
it's a lack of democratic functioning in
a sense democratic engagement that
allowed to to happen and I think what
happened in the Dutch my ancestry is
Dutch so I cared about him and so forth
so I think about what happened in the
Dutch case and is still happening is
that talented men had become a very
homogeneous society it for centuries had
had a Jewish component but it worked out
for commendations and then Jews held
honored positions in the society and so
forth and now suddenly and the Dutch
you're feeling good about themselves and
all of that now suddenly there's this
group who in all kinds of ways is simply
not part of the Dutch consensus they've
got no interest in participating in
Dutch government they do get goals from
the Dutch government and this is
resented of wet welfare from the Dutch
government and this is presented and so
forth so I think American society and
probably British society would have been
would be far better able to handle this
new group than the Dutch were they have
no experience with or the such
experiences they had was centuries in
the past this was outside the implicit
consensus that I don't know that I think
I actually think America would have
handled this better than either of our
I think European society I think you're
very constitution with the points you
make is one major reasonable and we're
much bigger I mean 15 million
homogeneous people suddenly you can as
opposed to how many do 300 million
whatever non homogeneous so